bundesinnenminister seehofer hat dem
kanzler der bundeskanzlerin offenbar
pläne präsentiert wonach das reisen in
deutschland drastisch eingeschränkt
werden könnte um die mutation von
corinna zu stoppen einzudämmen
alle weiteren informationen darüber und
er ist gott sei dank noch bei mir hat
unser bild vize paul ronzheimer das
reisen drastisch einschränken das war
einer dieser punkte die die kanzlerin
bereits am wochenende angesprochen hat
sie fragte ja warum können wir das
reisen nicht irgendwie verbieten
jetzt scheint es da zumindest seitens
des innenministeriums konkrete pläne zu
gehen genauso ist es patricia die
schalte am sonntagabend hat bereits
erste hinweise gegeben darauf dass die
kanzlerin dort schärfere massnahmen will
sehr denn dieser schalter auch bereits
gesagt gehabt dass sie bundes dass sie
horst seehofer gebeten hat pläne
vorzulegen jetzt wissen wir das ist ein
treffen gegeben hat im kanzleramt wo
horst seehofer konkret mit der kanzlerin
darüber gesprochen hat was man machen
kann um möglicherweise den flugverkehr
soll es die kanzlerin ja genannt
auszudünnen
horst seehofer hat zu bild gesagt im
anschluss an dieses treffen die
gefährdung die von den zahlreichen virus
mutationen ausgeht verlangt von uns dass
wir auch drastische maßnahmen prüfen und
in der bundesregierung diskutieren
dazu gehören deutlich schärfere
grenzkontrollen besonders an den grenzen
zu hoch risikogebieten aber auch die
reduzierung des flugverkehrs nach
deutschland auf nahezu null
so wie israel das derzeit macht um die
einschleppung der virus mutation zu
verhindern
die menschen in deutschland die menschen
die in deutschland harte einschränkungen
akzeptieren erwarten von uns dass wir
sie bestmöglich vor einer explosion der
infektionszahlen schützen aber keine
flug also eine reduzierung des des
flugverkehrs nach deutschland auf nahezu
null
was bedeutet das für uns konkret heißt
das wir dürfen weiterhin überall
hinfliegen aber zu uns darf keiner rein
wie könnte das aus paris ab zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt haben wir nicht mehr
informationen als diese was die
kanzlerin zum einen eben am sonntagabend
in der schalter gesagt hat wo sie das
jetzt entscheidenden punkt gezeichnet
hat
und jetzt eben dass es dieses treffen
gab woraus seehofer pläne vorgelegt hat
offenbar so scheint es hat er genau
diesen plan auch verfolgt wir wissen
dass in israel tatsächlich ist kaum noch
kaum noch flugverkehr gibt der dort
landet und der hintergrund weiter muss
man sagen ist die virus mutation also
was könnte zum beispiel passieren man
könnte anfangen damit den flugverkehr
insbesondere aus den mutations gebiet
nämlich großbritannien wissen wir ist ja
schon eingeschränkt gewesen aber auch
südafrika brasilien das einzuschränken
ich denke aber die pläne kanzlerin so
wie sie es will ist ja immer noch offen
ob das ganze dann auch umgesetzt wird
gehen aber darüber hinaus denn sie hat
ja ganz konkret nicht nur von mutations
gebieten gesprochen sondern sie hat in
dieser schalter am sonntagabend auch
kritisiert dass deutsche zu viel in den
urlaub fliegen sie hat sich bezogen auf
weihnachten und auf die kanaren von
daher muss man davon ausgehen dass sie
damit auch reisen meint jetzt nicht in
mutations gebiete gehen sondern weit
reichender wie genau diese pläne
aussehen könnten vor allem welche
chancen sie zur umsetzung haben das
können wir zum jetzigen zeitpunkt noch
nicht sagen was wir wissen
die kanzlerin möchte ist dass es klar
geworden am sonntagabend in dieser
geheim schalte heute das treffen horst
seehofer mit der kanzlerin wo er pläne
vorgelegt hat und dieser satz der für
mich entscheiden das den er hinterher zu
uns gesagt hat
dazu gehören deutlich schärfere
grenzkontrollen besonders an den grenzen
zu hoch risikogebieten aber auch die
reduzierung des flugverkehrs nach
deutschland auf nahezu null
so wie israel das derzeit auch macht um
die einschleppung der virus mutation zu
verhindern
das ist das entscheidende ist er auch
die rede davon dass vielen
fluggesellschaften ist offenbar schwer
fällt die korona regeln umzusetzen hier
steht drinnen
ja es gab 16 airlines die an einem
einzigen tag 250 mal gegen die korona
regeln verstoßen haben das auch eine
zahl die man hier zur analyse nimmt also
offenbar ist es auch schwer die
quarantäne gesetze zu überwachen
die abstände zu wahren im flugzeug
sowieso also die sorge dass hier die
mutation um sich greift und sich
in deutschland weiter ausbreitet scheint
groß zu sein mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bild schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren